ثمنا وزير الدفاع البريطاني بنوالس في
مقابلته الخاصه مع العربيه عمق العلاقات
مع السعوديه واكد ان العلاقات مع دول
الخليج لها اهميه قصوى بالنسبه لبريطانيا
على كافه المستويات
كانت جيده للغايه بقيت كذلك على مدى عقود
حتى قبل ان يبدا التعاون بين بلدينا في
مجال الفضاء والدفاع انا امثل شركه تعمل
في مقاطعه الانتخابيه هي شركه سعوديه
مصنعه لافضل انواع الاشمره التي تباع في
السعوديه هي موجوده منذ ثلاثينيات القرن
الماضي العلاقه الثنائيه قويه وعميقه
للغايه ولمنطقه الخليج اهميه قصوى بالنسبه
للمملكه المتحده على كافه الصعود
الاستراتيجيه منها او الاقتصاديه هذا يخدم
رفاهنا وهو امر ايجابي لقد عقدت اجتماعي
الثالث مع الامير خالد بن سلمان والتقيته
من قبل في لندن وكذلك هنا في المملكه قبل
عامين
وحول زيارته الى السعوديه قال بنولسين
وناقش مع وزير الدفاع السعوديه الامير
خالد بن سلمان عده قضايا من بينها اليمن
وايران واشاد برؤيه المملكه 2030 مؤكدا ان
بريطانيا مستعده لتقديم كافه اشكال الدعم
من اجل انجاحها
الهدف من زياره مواصله هذه العلاقه لان
العلاقات تعني الابقاء على الاتصال الدائم
بيننا ومناقشه القضايا اليوميه وكذلك بحث
الخطط بعيده المدى هو امر هام فانا اشغل
منصب وزير منذ فتره طويله واقامه علاقات
وثيقه ومناسبه مع نظراء يحدث بالفعل فارقا
الامير خالد صديق عزيز استطيع ان اتناول
معه كل القضايا وهذا ما حدث حيث بحثنا
قضايا اليمن وايران والقاعده الصناعيه
الطموحه في السعوديه فرؤيه المملكه 2030
مشروع غايه في الاهميه بالنسبه لنا نريد
ان تنجح هذه الرؤيه ومستعدون لتقديم كافه
اشكال الدعم من اجل انجاحها سواء تعلق
الامر بمجال الدفاع او اي قطاع اخر انضم
الينا من لندن مساعد رئيس تحرير صحيفه
الشرق الاوسط الصحفي زيد بن كمي سيد زيد
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض تابعت تصريحات من ولس والحديث
عن العلاقات السعوديه البريطانيه وبانها
علاقات قويه ومتينه هل وصلت برايك
بريطانيا اليوم لقناعه او تصور بضروره
تطوير وتعميق هذه العلاقه مع دول الخليج
خصوصا مع السعوديه ولماذا
مساء الخير اخي نايف مساء الخير للساده
والسيدات المشاهدين
حقيقه بريطانيا مهتمه بشكل كبير جدا مع
علاقتها مع السعوديه واحنا راينا في اكثر
واكثر من حديث للمسؤولين في في المملكه
المتحده
لانهم يعلمون
اهميه ايضا يعني ممتده تاريخيه ممتده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع بريطانيا
سنوات يعني طويله جدا من ايام تاسيس
الدوله السعوديه الاولى لكن احنا اتكلم
حاليا الان لما تاسس المجلس الشراكه في
حينما زار الامير محمد بن سلمان وهي العهد
البريطانيا في 2018 تاسست مجلس الشراكه
بين السعوديه وبريطانيا واعتقد الان هو
اكثر من اجتماع لدعم يعني العلاقات وايضا
لتسهيل
تسهيل ايضا يعني ما تم الاتفاق عليه او
متابعتها ايضا في خلال الاجتماعات السابقه
نحن نعرف انه مثلا بريطانيا يعني مهتمه
بشكل كبير جدا نكون على يعني رفع الميزان
التجاري بينها وبين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اضافه ان
لديها اهتمام ايضا كذلك في كثير من
القطاعات في المكرمه السعوديه فيما يخص
ايضا رؤيه 2030 ماذا عن عن الرؤى السياسيه
البلدين سيد زيدين يمكن ان تلتقي هذه
الرؤى اين يمكن ان
تختلف وكذلك هل اليوم العلاقات السعوديه
البريطانيه يمكن توصيفها بانها في حاله
افضل او في حاله يعني افضل مما كانت عليه
قبل اربع الى خمس سنوات
اعتقد صحيح العلاقات السعوديه البريطانيه
هي
في هناك يعني هناك رغبه شديده جدا من سواء
من جهه
البريطانيا لتقويه العلاقات في في شتى
المجالات حتى ايضا بعض الخلافات في موضوع
في السياسه الخارجيه لكن ايضا هناك احترام
لكن هناك اعتقد في ملف الان اعتقد ان حمل
الملفات ملف اليمن ملف اليمن الان احنا
نعلم ان في لجنه رباعيه وايضا منها
بريطانيا والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
واعتقد ان هذا الملف ملف مهم جدا
الملف سيد زيد في هذا الحوار ابقى معي اذا
مشاهدينا كما اتهم بن ولس في مقابلته
الخاصه مع العربيه تم ايران بزعزعه
الاستقرار في المنطقه مؤكدا ان كافه
الخيارات مطروحه للتعامل مع طهران وحذر
ولسه من ان امتلاك ايران لسلاح سيكون مبعث
قلق عالمي
اعتقد ان هناك خيارات كثيره لا احد يستبعد
اي خيار على الطاوله لكن لا اعتقد انه امر
جيد سيكون سيئا للغايه بالنسبه للمنطقه
لانه سيطلق العنان لسباق تسلح النووي
ونعتقد ان السلوك الايراني في الوقت
الراهن سلوك لا يتحلى بالمسؤوليه ويتسبب
بزعزعه الاستقرار على وتن على انه سلوك
عدواني سواء تعلق الامر بالعراق او اليمن
او تجاه السعوديه وسيثبت بان نظاما يمتلك
سلاح نووي سيكون خطيرا للغايه ومبعثا
للقلق البالغ بالنسبه لنا جميعا لذلك
اتصور ان المجتمع الدولي يشعر بقلق بالغ
لانه بذر جهودا كبيره للتواصل لخطه العمل
الشامله المشتركه وهي معاهده اتفقنا عليها
جميعا قبل سنوات ما يجب القيام به محاوله
العوده الى ذلك الوضع
الوزير البريطانيه اضافه للعربيه بان
الشحنه الاسلحه الايرانيه المتطوره التي
تم ضبطها في المياه الدوليه جنوب ايران
تمثل خرقا لقرارات الامم المتحده مؤكدا
بان الحرس الثوري الايراني له صله بهذه
الشحنات
كان القارب يتواجد على بعد اميال جنوب غرب
ايران وقامت باعتراضه سفينه اتش ام اس
لانجستر التابعه للبحريه الملكيه
البريطانيه خلال عمليه تفتيش القارب
اكتشفت على متنه شحنه من الاسلحه المتنوعه
تشمل اسلحه مضاده للدبابات وكذلك مكونات
محتمله لصواريخ باليسيه هذا امر يثير
قلقنا البالغ لانه خرق للحظر المفروض من
قبل الامم المتحده وقد تم مصادره الاسلحه
التي سنقوم بفحصها من اجل معرفه وجهتها
ومصدرها في عام 2022 اعترضت السفينه اتش
ام اس قريبين كان يقومان بتهريب الاسلحه
التي اكتشفنا انها لم تكن تضم مكونات
الاسلحه البالسيه واسلحه مضاده للدبابات
فحسب وانما ايضا تضمنت محركات لصواريخ
كروز مصدرها ايران كانت للحرس الثوري صله
بها وهذا طبعا يعتبر خرقا للحظر الذي
تفرضه الامم المتحده
هذا امر يثير قلقا بالغا لان طلوع ايران
في الاحداث الجاريه في اليمن يزعزع
الاستقرار ولا مصلحه لاي طرف فيه فهو لا
يفيد الحوثيين وبالتاكيد لا يفيد اي طرف
لكنه يمثل ايضا تهديدا للامن والاستقرار
في العالم انتم هنا في السعوديه لكم بعض
من هذه الدخائر وهم يقولون ان من اطلقها
الحوثيون لكن الشخص الذي يسلح الحوثيين
يتحمل ذاك المسؤوليه اعود مره اخرى الى
ضيفي زيد بن كمي مساعد رئيس تحرير الشرق
الاوسط مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى الوزير
البريطاني تحدث عن شحنه الاسلحه الايرانيه
التي تم فيها الحرس الثوري الايراني بانه
هو من كان طبعا وراء هذه العمليه ومحاوله
نقل هذه الاسلحه ربما الى الحوثين في
اليمن اسال هنا عن الدوله البريطاني اليوم
في حل هذه الازمه اليمنيه كيف تقرا هل
يمكن ان يكون هناك
يعني محل ترعه بريطاني في هذه الازمه
اليمنيه الراهنه ام سنستمر في مزيد من
الصراع مزيد من التاجيج في ضوء ما قاله
بين ولس
وهي تسمى صاحبه القلم او حامله القلم فيما
يخص ايضا في القرارات العموميه او تقديم
القرارات المجلس الامن المتحده فيما يخص
الملف اليمني وهي تدعم ايضا
فتى حل يعني الازمه في اليمن يعني هي
تشارك حتى يعني المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والبريطاني متفقين عليها وضروره حل الازمه
بين اليمنيين انفسهم وهي الدوله ترى
ان التدخل الايراني والدخول الايراني هو
مزعزع لامن واستقرار المنطقه وايضا فيما
يخص الملف في اليمن هو ايضا التدخل
الايراني ليس لحل القضيه باليمن بل هو
يعني زياده اشعال
يعني تغير الموقف تجاه ايران فيما يخص هذه
الاسلحه فيما يخص الزوارق التي ضبطت حتى
فيما يخص البرنامج النووي الايراني
والتدخلات حتى ايران في دول المنطقه هل
يمكن ان تنعكس
وجهه النظر البريطانيه والتغير في الموقف
البريطاني على حلحله الازمه في اليمن ام
انها ستتعامل مع كل موضوع على حده
لبنان وايضا في اليمن لكن لو احنا ناخذ
قضيه اليمن من وحدها صحيحه ان الايران هي
دوله يعني
ليست حل الازمه اللي هي تزيد الازمه سوا
لذلك حينما تحدث الوزير عن الدور الايراني
هو لا بد ان ايقاف الدور الايراني في
الملف اليمني اشكرك جزيل الشكر